no but yeah you're looking you're
looking very good thank you you should
try it are these like I wear fake
glasses are these fake glasses though
fake glasses yeah I've worn them
sometimes yeah I can't I can't believe
this my eyesight I Harry Potter
so this is a fashion statement of course
it's for making a fashion statement my
my eyesight's 2020. excuse me it's
literally a fashion statement my
eyesight is not your fashion Joey I'm
preparing myself for when my eyesight I
wasn't born with short sight in this
just so you can wear it I I have some
fake lashes at home that I've worn many
times yeah that's good on you bad bad
eyesight isn't just something that you
can take on and off Joey you have to
live with it okay I can't believe you do
me like this Joey
you can't see anyways
no I've just I've just gotten used to
wearing like a lifestyle of contactless
because I'm I'm preparing myself because
I know for a fact when my eyesight turns
to [ __ ] at old age I'll be too much of a
[ __ ] to try and put contacts yeah
because I can't my eyes are too
sensitive I can't do it do you know do
you know one weird life hack I found I
find out like be rich
aside from be rich so I saw the scene in
an anime
one character has like short-sightedness
and like if you make like oh [ __ ] they
fixed it with the pinhole thing right
and I'm like what [ __ ] [ __ ] is
this and I actually memeed it in one of
my videos yeah and then then the
comments are just like no it actually
works it actually works trust me trust
me and I'm like okay wait what is it so
what what you do right is you just make
a pinhole with uh you make a pinhole
basically a pinhole with like your hand
or something and you look through it and
then you're meant to be able to focus
even if you have like short-sightedness
I was like this is absolute [ __ ] and
then I tried it and then it worked I was
like what Oh I thought you brought that
up and it was [ __ ] no I I want I
thought it was I thought it was [ __ ]
so what you're suggesting is that people
have bad eyesight should wear glasses
where the glasses like this big
tiny ones
uh 30 H3 the what's that band called uh
three they should wear those glasses
I don't know what the [ __ ] science is
it's like insane but I'm like why like
something about my eyes is broken if all
I need to do is do this and granted I
can only read like because how I tested
it out was I was like normally I cannot
read subtitles at all if I'm watching on
TV that's absolutely impossible for me
but like do this look at it through a
pinhole and suddenly I can see like one
word at a time I can only see one word
at a time but for some reason it works I
I have no idea I have no idea what it's
basically the thing you know in school
when you were learning how to read and
you use the ruler yeah
it's just that it's just like one word
it's just one word at a time yeah I I
have no idea why this life hack Works
found out about it somehow it's not
[ __ ] science explains science please
wait yeah which anime did you see it in
uh it was like an isakai Pharmacy of
course of course it was it was the
isekai pharmacy anime
I was imagining Dr Stone as well okay
yeah I don't know I don't know why that
works like body stupid or something like
that
brain dumb yeah wait so how bad is your
eyesight my eyesight's pretty bad it's
not like awful awful bad oh when did it
start getting bad
so I don't think it's all the story I I
don't know if I've told the story uh
maybe I have but I've I've started
getting bad when I was like a teenager
not a teenager like a kid oh [ __ ] like a
kid so like right when I was like
Primary School yeah Primary School
um and I'm gonna kind of call out my mum
for a second here because she's gonna
stick this too yeah she's gonna see this
but she can confirm that this happened
because back in the day
um I was like sitting really close to
the TV and my mum was just like don't
sit close to the TV your eyesight is
going to get worse
and so I was like I was like but mum I
can't really see the TV right now she's
just like it's because you're playing
too many video games yeah just just try
harder just look harder okay but just
keep your eyesight just keep your
eyesight and check okay and then I do
this
basically it was like the most Asian
like it was like the most Asian advice
you could ever think of it was just like
just just
she was like son just uh just get good
just get a good eyesight and it was only
like until like I was like it was like
three years down the line when we just
had this [ __ ] realization of oh maybe
I'm just short-sighted so wait was it
because I've always been interested so
was it like when you when your eyesight
goes bad when you're a child right yeah
is it like a gradual thing over like
many years to the point where Suddenly
It's like the change is so slow that you
don't notice the change happening until
it's too late or is it literally like
you wake up one more and you're like I
can't [ __ ] see
um honestly I my eyesight was bad to the
point where look it's it's always been
bad to the point where I don't remember
ever having good eyesight I don't think
I've ever had a perfect eyesight I've
just like my some of my earliest
memories are having something on TV and
just me going ah I need to sit this I
need to sit like this close to the TV in
order to see the TV like I've never I've
never sat on the couch and be like okay
I see the TV I've always had to sound
like near the TV
um obviously that was you know what made
my back my eyesight bad
in the first place uh according to Asian
parents but uh no like I've I've always
had bad eyesight and it was only when I
was like seven ish that I did that I got
my first glasses and I remember the
first time putting on glasses and I was
like holy [ __ ] this is a life hack
what is this people's people see like
this normally yeah what well I think I
saw that it was a long time ago there
was this like uh artist this digital
artist that like Drew watercolor
paintings of what it would what the
world looks like to people who have bad
eyesight and I and like what looking at
that painting as someone with normal
eyesight I was just like this is giving
me a headache yeah I'm like I'm like
damn y'all live like this
it's like holy [ __ ] so that's I think
it's after that that I saw that that
made me go like okay I need to like
really take care of my eyesight so like
now whenever I'm like sitting in front
of a computer or a TV or whatever or if
even if I'm like staring at my phone for
a long time I always wear my blue light
glasses because I've always had really
really sensitive eyes I don't know why
because like can you guys open your eyes
in a pool yes I can't do it because like
the moment I open my eyes I can
physically feel my eyes burning oh yeah
no I can yeah everyone's does yeah
but mine Burns
mine Burns extra hard but also like I
just get better eyesight
just bought goggles
but like you know because when you see
especially in Australia right because
it's like you know Summers get really
hot and in Australia you always have
that one friend who has a pool in their
house right so you go you go swim in
there Paul and then you know there's
that moment usually in like early like
middle school late Elementary School
where you start to be like I don't need
goggles I'm not a child anymore I'll
just I'll just jump in like the adults
do and just open my eyes underwater so
there was there was that you know that
happened I was just like yeah yeah I'm
I'm also an adult now I will try it as
well so I jump in I'm just like but
instinctively you're like I don't want
to open my eyes right it's gonna hurt
I'm like [ __ ] it I'm an adult dinner
once and then my room you jump with your
eyes open no no no no I jump in with my
eyes closed
directly in your eyes
I think that's just gonna
I remember I didn't even jump in the
pool I was on the edge of the pool and I
just stuck my face in the water
all right I'm gonna Open my
mind for like
one second and I was like it feels like
someone's stabbing my eyebrow I think
that's normal though but I pulled my
eyes out and all the whites in my eyes
were just bloodshot red yeah and my
parents are like oh that's that's not
normal that's like that's more red than
usual I think I think that's normal is
it yeah why would you want to do that
um normally it's like you you're doing
it for like 10 minutes tops like you're
not doing it 10 minutes I could barely
do it for two seconds
I I've done like whole swimming sessions
like an hour doing it and it [ __ ]
hurts afterwards but it's like I've got
to see where I'm going
one session
your Sailors like Sailors in the [ __ ]
City or something like yeah oh no I'm
drowning but I can't open it
I don't have my goggles
a lot of pathogens and [ __ ] that's true
that's true I mean I'm not I'm not like
I mean if I need I don't like it but if
I need to see underwater
Beach I've never brought goggles to the
beach oh yeah no I'm not in the beach
either but I'm also not opening my eyes
on the water when I'm at the beach no I
try not because most times my head is
above water anyway yeah water in your
eyes yeah no I get like a little you
know Splash so so is so it is blind
you're like my I have chlorine ten
simply in my eyes but I also have have I
I but I realize that it's not just the
chlorine for me it's that like now now
like if I stare at a TV for more than
five minutes without my blue eyeglasses
I get a headache